- We both started on "Idol."
- [Kellie] Yes.
- And I had no idea until
literally last night
that one of your audition songs
was "Since You Been Gone."
- Yes,
Oh my gosh.
- I love that!
I didn't know that.
- Yes, well big fan.
- Well, thank you.
- No, I remember auditioning, you know,
there's so many different rounds.
- [Kelly] Before you even get to the.
- Before you even get to
Paula, Randy, and Simon,
which we had the original three.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Kellie] My gosh.
- That's so cute.
- Time doesn't slow down
for nobody, does it.
(Kelly laughs)
But so, we go in.
I actually auditioned
with "The Sweetest Thing"
by Juice Newton.
- Yeah.
- Went through to the next round
and then sang that one
again and I thought,
maybe this'll be good.
Keep doin' this one.
And I think it was Paula had
asked me to sing something,
could you sing something pop?
And I went, I just
started singing your song.
And I was terrified because.
- You picked,
I mean I gotta be real with you,
that would not be my
go-to for an audition.
- I mean, I didn't know
and you were the first
person that came to mind.
And then 20 seconds of something else,
and so I sang "Broken
Wing" by Martina McBride.
- Good song, good pick.
They had me do the same thing.
- You're a good luck charm
- They had all of us do
different songs
- for me.
It got me through to the next round.
- Well that's awesome.
They had all of us do that though.
Everybody thinks it's like one song.
I had to sing like three different ones
even to get, yeah.
I was like am I still proving
that I can sing on key here?
What's happening.
- This is amazing backstage
dish to "American Idol."
We are spilling the tea today.
- [Kelly] We are!
- Everywhere!
- (laughs) I love you.